I know your attitude towards this is
sort of that you're just watching back
and laughing as it all happens before
your eyes and I get that because I'm
overseas and I'm enjoying life in
different parts of Europe and would not
even think about dating an Australian
girl
um but I've still got that part of me
that wants to fight for the West you
know even though it might be too far
gone and I've got that part of me that
wants to just uh embrace the ideas of
Christianity and the nuclear family and
wants to embody what I want to see in
the world but when you're watching a
train wreck happen before your eyes
sometimes I feel like it's there's no
point standing in front of the train
going no I'll stop you because there's
not much you can do about it that's a
great analogy because that's essentially
what you're up against you're trying to
stop a freight train with a hundred cars
behind it and three locomotive engines
pushing it through with just your hands
stopping stopping it on the tracks
that's this that's the size of the
problem that we're up against sure I'd
love to see The Return of the nuclear
family femininity masculinity
conventional masculinity conventional
femininity
you know women being a compliment to a
man's life you know a man providing a
man having you know authority over his
household
um with the responsibility to it you
know the conventional things that made
my grandfather my great grandfather is
my you know like down you know through
those paths that you know allowed me to
exist today but I don't think that we're
going to return to that time anytime
soon there's a there's a cultural shift
that's again you know it's it's trying
to pacify and weaken and soften the
Western mail it's trying to tell women
to become more like men again you know
put off having families put off having
children go climb the corporate ladder
get degrees frame them and mahogany put
them on the wall get promoted I mean
it's why we have so many single
childless women women now in their late
30s desperate with baby rabies to have
children on dating apps after they've
been run through by 50 to 100 guys
trying to hold out Purity and you know
getting right with God and wanting to
get married I mean one of the big
problems that I see with religion today
and it and like the original rule book
does have great points right you know if
you follow the original rule book
um I think that it that it that it's a
good set of guidelines the problem is
today is that most churches in most
religions are basically beta factories
right
um
you see it all the time in these men's
discussion groups like I'm in a few of
them on Facebook and you'll get some
dork that's like my wife hasn't slept
with me and uh you know I don't know
three or four months uh blah blah blah
and I want to be intimate with her and
you know she says do more chores or or
some guys will chime in and be like well
what's her love language you know sort
of thing because my wife's love language
is this and if you read this love
language book that you can also get you
know basic starfish missionary sex like
I do you know once every month as well
and it's like losers right like these
guys are not living their best life and
you know to some degree it's not really
their fault you know they've been
programmed with a sequence of lies and
that they've consumed and
they're drunk on this Kool-Aid and and
they're living this Narrative of things
like chore play like if I just change
enough diapers and and and and iron
enough shirts and do the laundry and cut
the grass and swap the snow tires for
the summer Tires she'll eventually bang
me you know enthusiastically and that's
not the way it works it's never worked
that way and these guys inherently know
this like they know if they go back in
their minds to where they first met
their wife before they got married
before they were engaged when they had
uh enthusiastic rough monkey sucks in
the back seat of their parents car or in
a parking lot somewhere you know they
know what it what genuine desire looks
like but through a process of
betaization through a thousand
concessions which usually starts with
something like don't brush your teeth
over there you're going to get it on the
carpet put the black socks in the black
hamper and the white socks and a white
hamper like they go through the sequence
of yes yes yes yes yes yes honey to
everything and they don't have a
backbone and they don't know how to lead
and they don't know how to set the tone
and they don't know how to say no but
they end up in a point where they're on
a men's you know discussion board
talking about God Jesus and doing more
chore play just to get some pathetic
starfish sex once every six months right
so
um I know that's a bit of a rant but I
don't see culture shifting in a large
enough degree where there's ever going
to be a return to the conventional Norms
that we operated in for millions of
years I think this this shift in the
last
it's probably since I'd say the 60s 70s
like since hormonal birth control
um you know since that shift that things
have just been on the decline you know
progressively
and I feel like it's what you say about
betatization through a thousand
concessions like what you just said all
of the little concessions that you
constantly give away I feel like on the
micro level that's true then on the
macro level that's also true in terms of
society and the way that men have danced
around these issues over the last 60
years or whatever and we don't like we
don't have a collective backbone anymore
either and then every time somebody
tries to stand up and say hey I'm gonna
no cut them down and basically on
them so I think you and I would both be
uh be happy to see The Return of you
know nuclear family and values and you
know maybe it does turn around I'm still
somewhat hopeful but it's not looking
great the good news is that is what is
attractive still to women you know the
good news is that strong virtuous Alpha
topa men are what women are
authentically attracted to
um and your competition has never been
lower than ever like all that my
great-grandfather needed to do was be
basically go and fight in a war probably
and come back and get a job and that job
was enough you know to provide for a
family have a house have a stay-at-home
wife you know a bunch of kids everything
taken care of
um for today's modern women that's not
even close to enough anymore you've got
to be over six foot two you've got to
make uh 250 000 a year you got to drive
a really nice car you gotta you know
they've got this long laundry humble
nice funny sweet Alpha Beta it's like it
keeps going and going and going and
going sort of thing and it's like
and what do most women bring to the
table
usually like a body count of 50 and
they're selling Purity and they want to
be a wife right uh you know many cases
they're bringing some other dudes kids
sometimes for multiple fathers right
like like today's modern women generally
speaking and you know you sort of
alluded to this mentioning that you
rarely date women from Australia
um and I get it because women in Eastern
Europe are far more feminine they're
more conventional they're more
conservative they're more willing to
enter the frame of a strong masculine
man
um so there is some Beacon of Hope
that's why I'm more you know along the
lines of just enjoy the decline look at
the game understand the rules play
Within it and optimize yourself as best
as you can because you can still have a
great life as a guy today you can still
if you want to catch children you can
still do that if you want to have a
girlfriend if you if you want to you
know take on the risk of marriage you
know you can do all of those things if
you like and if you do it right and
you're a strong enough guy that's done
the work on themselves you'll stand out
from the crowd easily very very easily
because the competition has never been
weaker than what it is today I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out